bonsoir vous savez je crois que je suis
un privilégié j'ai eu la chance de
recevoir une éducation dans un pays
développé comme le nôtre d'avoir mon bac
à 18 ans comme il se doit
très bien puis de suivre des études
d'ingénieur pendant cinq ans et d'avoir
mon diplôme d'ingénieur en poche à l'âge
de 23 ans parfait en théorie je n'ai
aucune raison de me plaindre
en théorie je ne devrais pas me plaindre
et pourtant pendant toutes ces années il
ya quelque chose qui marche i phone est
quelque chose qui m'a un petit peu
torturer l'esprit quelque chose qui me
disaient que ça ne tournait pas aussi
rond parce que ça aurait dû pourquoi et
bien vous allez voir où je veux en venir
vous et moi on ne se connaît pas a
priori
et pourtant je suis prêt à parier que
nous avons reçu une éducation base est
exactement sur le même modèle ce modèle
quel est il vous aviez un emploi du
temps pour la semaine le lundi tél
courtel cours le mardi tel cours tels
cours vous entrez dans une salle de
cours
vous vous asseyez sur une chaise pendant
une heure si vous avez de la chance
pendant deux heures si vous avez un peu
moins de chance et vous écoutez votre
professeur parler et vous enseigner tout
ce qu'il sait vous écoutez en fait le
discours d'un homme et vous prenez des
notes inlassablement et pendant ce temps
là le professeur fait la même chose
il répète encore encore et encore le
même court
inlassablement plusieurs fois dans la
semaine à plusieurs personnes à
plusieurs classes différentes
et il répète ça chaque année encore et
encore
ce modèle d'éducation il fait partie de
nos vies nous avons l'habitude de
recevoir une éducation de cette femme là
en fait c'est le modèle d'éducation
existe depuis très longtemps et il n'a
pratiquement pas changé
ce que vous voyez ici c'est une gravure
qui représente les arts et métiers il ya
plus de 200 ans
qu'est ce que vous y voyez vous y voyez
un professeur sur son pupitre peut-être
sur une estrade devant un tableau blanc
ou un tableau noir qui dispense son
discours à une assemblée de personnes
qui écoutent bien silencieusement et qui
prennent des notes
je ne sais pas quels souvenirs vous avez
des amphithéâtres pour ma part si on me
dit amphithéâtre je me souviendrai
plutôt de ça oui parce que
l'amphithéâtre
c'était toujours le même théâtre c'était
la même règle à chaque fois nous avions
un nouveau professeur et nous venions en
nombre écouter son discours
et puis comme par magie la deuxième fois
au deuxième court 50% voire même 80% de
l'effectif avait fondu et noël c'est
plus personne et le peu de personnes qui
restait avait l'air de s'ennuyer ferme
alors vous pourrez tirer des conclusions
en voyant cette image on pourrait se
dire c'est peut-être que le professeur
n'était pas très intéressant c'est
peut-être que les élèves finalement ne
sont pas très attentifs sont dissipés
peut-être que les élèves d'aujourd'hui
sont moins attentifs qu'hier j'ai
entendu et longtemps encore mais on
s'est jamais posé la question du
fonctionnement du système
peut-être que ça ne fonctionne pas aussi
bien que ce qu'on voudrait parce que le
système n'a pas changé depuis des
siècles et peut-être parce qu'il ne
s'est pas adapté
à nouveau à nouveau mode de vie et à de
nouvelles façons d'apprendre auquel nous
aspirons
vous vous souvenez peut-être par exemple
des salles d'examen qui ressemblait à
priori à ceux ci où vous étiez assis et
pendant 1h 2h 4h même pour le bac vous
pouviez rester et rédigé rédigé rédigé
renvoyer votre copie et avoir une note
généralement sur 20 en espérant qu'il
soit la plus élevée possible pour
satisfaire l'adulte qui vous a enseigné
et non pas pour satisfaire votre soif
d'apprendre et votre curiosité vous
souvenez peut-être aussi en tout cas
c'est un souvenir que j'ai moi de la
classe de sixième quand vous arrivez au
collège et que votre sac est
littéralement remplies d'ouvragés les
ouvrages que vous rajouter dans le sac
le matin en vous disant que vous n'avez
pas ce cours là mais peut-être aller que
vous aurez le temps d'étudier là dessus
on ne sait jamais si jamais un cours et
déplacés or vous pouvez le sac vous
bourrez le sac est comme moi vous êtes
comme ça et vous partez pour votre
journée de travail
alors mon but ce n'est pas de dire que
l'éducation actuelle pose des problèmes
de dos je laisse ça aux spécialistes
je m'intéresse plutôt au système en fait
en lui-même et à ce que cet enfant que
voyez sur la photo peut prendre comme
plaisir à aller à l'école et à apprendre
de nouvelles choses
parce que si j'ai une conviction c'est
que nous aimons tous apprendre nous
avons simplement oublié à quel point il
est bon d'apprendre
parce que nous n'avons pas toujours eu
les meilleures conditions pour apprendre
alors j'ai une histoire un petit peu
singulière parce que j'ai été à mon tour
enseignant alors que j'étais encore au
collège
en fait la photo vous voyez là c'est une
photo authentique noël 1998 mes parents
m'ont offert comme je leur avais demandé
un livre sur la programmation html
parce que je voulais apprendre à créer
un site web alors j connaissez rien
j'avais eu un ordinateur à la maison et
je m'amusais le démarrer à lancer des
jeux et puis un jour j'ai voulu être un
peu plus créatifs et apprendre à créer
un site web et l époque qu'est ce que
vous faisiez vous alliez en librairie et
vous preniez le livre qui passait sous
la main et c'est tout ce que vous aviez
ce livre a eu le mérite certes de me
mettre le pied à l'étrier
mais il m'a ouvert les yeux sur les
problèmes et les faiblesses de nos modes
d'éducation
pourquoi parce que tout simplement j'ai
lu ce livre est la première fois eh ben
j'ai rien compris mais vraiment j'ai
rien compris
l'auteur faisait des choses qui peuvent
paraître aberrante
quand je vous dis comme ça et pourtant
c'est vrai ils utilisaient des mots et
il est défini ses cinquante pages plus
loin pourquoi je juste pourquoi avoir
décidé de fonctionner comme ça pourquoi
avoir utilisé un langage un peu abscons
et des mots complexes pour m'apprendre
mois qui débute et a créé un site web
j'avais le sentiment que c'était quelque
chose qui était toujours réservé à une
élite quelque chose qui était
inaccessible
alors j'ai été un peu frustré mais j'ai
tenu bon et j'ai relu cet ouvrage puis
j'en ai acheté d'autres je vous avouerai
mais à chaque fois j'ai eu le même
sentiment que ce livre était déjà
dessiné un petit peu à une élite
et d'ailleurs quand vous regardez la
quatrième de couverture de ses ouvrages
il est toujours indiqué qu'il faut avoir
un déjà un bon niveau un niveau correct
une expérience passée dans la création
de site web alors je vous imagine bien
devant un tel livre dit mais voilà c'est
pas le lit pour moi parce que c'est pas
un livre pour moi qui débute
donc vous leur posez vous en cherchez un
et en vain parce que vous ne trouvez pas
l'ouvragé qui fait pour vous alors je me
suis posé la question qu'est-ce que je
peux faire pour ça j'avais des amis au
collège qui voulait aussi apprendre à
créer des sites web
ils m'ont demandé quel bouquin je
pouvais leur recommander imaginez bien
que je l'aurais pas recommandée suis là
et je me suis dit en fait je vois pas
quel est l'endroit que je peux leur
recommander pour apprendre à créer
ensuite
alors faute de l'avoir trouvé cet
endroit j'ai décidé de le créer on était
en 99
j'étais au collège en quatrième j'ai
pris de mon temps libre le soir et le
week-end pour réaliser mon premier site
web dont la mission serait d'expliquer
aux autres comment créer des sites web
c'était l'occasion pour moi de
m'entraîner a créé un site web c'est un
petit peu ironique mais surtout c'était
l'occasion pour moi d'enseigner à mes
amis sur une plateforme
comment créer un site web de la façon
dont moi j'aurais aimé l'apprendre et
j'insiste beaucoup j'ai réécrit
cet ouvrage de la façon dont moi
j'aurais aimé l'apprendre en 99 après un
petit peu de travail
ça a donné ça on ne rigole pas s'il vous
plaît
j'ai débuté et en fait avec un peu de
recul je me dis j'ai vraiment bien fait
de faire ça parce que j'étais pas bon et
j'ai bien fait de le faire j'ai bien
fait parce que c'était fait parce que
j'avais une idée
et cette idée gelé produite en fait je
lui donner vie les années ont passé et
j'ai continué à collaborer sur le site à
produire des courts sur des sujets qui
me passionnait souvent liées à
l'informatique est de plus en plus sur
d'autres matières et le site lui-même a
évolué il a évolué à tel point que
quelques années plus tard je me suis dit
mais j'adore créer des courts mais je
vois qu'il ya des gens qui apprennent
sur mon site et peut-être que ces
gens-là aimerait à leur tour
écrire des cours alors nous avons lancé
une nouvelle version de ce site
nous l'avons fait évolué de telle sorte
que chacun pourrait à son tour devenir
enseignant les sommes partis du principe
fondateur qu'il n'y avait pas besoin
d'avoir un cv de 20 pages pour avoir le
droit de publier un cours sur ce site
nous sommes partis du principe que nous
publierions des cours sur ce site que si
respecté l'état d'esprit dans lequel
nous avions lancé le site ça l'esprit
il est un petit peu difficile à définir
il se veut simplement accessible humains
empathique je crois que nous avons pas
mal parlé et ce sont des choses qui ont
en réalité mis en place toute une
dynamique tout un écosystème toute une
communauté de personnes qui apprennent
et qui à leur tour rendre à la
communauté et enseignes et créent de
nouveaux cours bien des années plus tard
le site existe toujours en fait et a
grandi j'ai eu mon diplôme d'ingénieur
entre temps et j'ai décidé de fonder une
start up
le site a changé de nom mais il est
resté le même et propose aujourd'hui
plus de 850 cours en ligne accessible
gratuitement ce site est aujourd'hui
alors je vous parle visité par 2 5
millions de personnes par mois et nous
n'avons jamais fait un seul centime de
dépenses de publicité ces visiteurs sont
venus uniquement par le bouche à oreille
parce qu'un ami leur a dit je te
conseille d'aller sur ce site parce que
là bas j'ai enfin compris alors le site
à évoluer les méthodes ont évolué mais
le discours est volontairement toujours
resté le même vous voyez ici nous
faisons aujourd'hui beaucoup de vidéos
mais nous n'oublions pas de recentrer
l'humain dans ces vidéos la l'humain
c'est le professeur qui a quelque chose
à vous partager mais il souhaite vous le
faire d'une façon totalement accessible
humaine est en réalité nous avons
découvert par expérience que la plupart
des gens ont peur d'apprendre quelque
chose de nouveau parce que ils pensent
qu'ils n'en sont pas capables et dans un
cours comme celui ci on estime qu'on
passe entre 25 et 30 % de notre temps à
rassurer le lecteur sur sa capacité à
aller jusqu'au bout
en fait nous faisons de la psychologie
alors quand on parle d'internet
on pense souvent à un réseau
d'ordinateurs interconnectés entre eux
comme ici mais ce que je pense ce que
j'ai découvert en fait c'est que ces
ordinateurs cachent des humains et qu'en
réalité nous sommes derrière un réseau
d'humains qui n'ont qu'un désir c'est
d'échanger avec leurs pairs et de
prendre du plaisir à apprendre et
enseigner à leur tour aujourd'hui je
suis vraiment heureux d'avoir pu montrer
qu' un tel système est possible qu'un
tel système est viable puisque nous
gagnons de l'argent plus d'1 5 million
d'euros par an avec ce système que ce
système fait des émules et donne à de
nouvelles pertes en vies à nouvelles
personnes de créer à leur tour des sites
web d'enseigner dans de nouvelles
matières donnant vie à des professeurs
en école et en université de s'inspirer
des méthodes que nous avons proposé pour
à leur tour diffuser la connaissance
d'une façon nouvelle et agréable et puis
nous avons récemment fait en sorte que
au sein même d'un cours les étudiants
puissent se corriger entre eux oui vous
avez bien entendu je parle d'étudiants
qui ne connaisse à priori rien un sujet
et à qui on demande de corriger des
devoirs qui vient d'être fait par leurs
collègues qui viennent d'apprendre le
même sujet ce système qu'on appelle la
correction entre pairs n'est pas nouveau
mais à l'échelle d'internet
il permet aujourd'hui de faire des
choses extraordinaires
alors je vous parle un marocain peut
corriger un français un français peut
publier un cours en ligne qui va lui par
un canadien qui va être lu lé par un
suisse qui à son tour va proposer des
exercices qui vont se faire corriger par
toute une communauté de membres
ce système il fonctionne ce système il
ne demande qu'à grandir et
a poussée au-delà des portes du web à
rentrer dans le monde de l'éducation de
l'enseignement de l'université
c'est ce que l'on appelle aujourd'hui
beaucoup dans les médias les mook
massive open online course des cours en
ligne ouvert et massif ce que nous avons
découvert que nous faisions en réalité
depuis déjà 15 ans et il ya une vague de
fond aujourd'hui et je souhaite vraiment
la partager aujourd'hui avec vous parce
que elle lance un nouvel espoir pour
l'éducation et il ne faut pas perdre de
vue que c'est nous humains qui sommes
acteurs de ce changement
c'est à nous d'apprendre et un autre
tour d'enseigner à nos collègues
s'il ya une chose que j'aimerais que
vous reteniez de cette présentation
c'est que on ne peut réussir un cours
passionnant que si l'on fait réellement
une aventure et on découvre avec joie le
plaisir de voir le chemin que l'on a
gravi en l'apprenant en enseignant à son
tour à nos pères et ce plaisir que je
rencontre chaque jour tout simplement je
vous souhaite de le rencontrer à votre
tour merci à tous